et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Sandrine Rousseau bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous députés
écologiste de Paris membre de la nuit
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Fabrice wesser au don du
groupe Ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'Est de la France
on va évidemment parler de votre partie
mais d'abord Emmanuel Macron et la Coupe
du Monde au Qatar Emmanuel Macron qui a
fait ce tweet il y a quelques heures et
qui dit que cette Coupe du monde le site
témoigne de changement concrets qui sont
à l'oeuvre le Qatar c'est engagé dans
cette voie il doit continuer il peut
compter sur notre soutien c'est ce que
dit Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce tweet
je pense que c'est un tweet de
circonstance et que la réalité c'est que
ce type d'événement sportif la Coupe du
Monde au Qatar ça ne fait que banaliser
et ça ne fait que rendre acceptable des
des pays et des régimes qui sont en
réalité totalitaire ça n'engage pas dans
la voie du changement comme le dit chef
de l'État au contraire ça lui est
banalise ça les conforte ça les
acceptable et pourquoi tout cela mais
parce qu'en fait on est dépendant au
pétrole voilà et que
tant qu'on ne réglera pas cette
dépendance au pétrole et bien on devra
faire des rondes jambes devant des
régimes qui ne sont pas fréquentables en
réalité on le voit avec les ouvriers qui
ont construit les stades on le voit avec
les personnes
lgbtqia plus qui sont quand même
torturés enfin je veux dire
en quoi le Qatar s'ouvre-t-il mais ça
vous choque pas ce tweet ça vous choque
mais bien sûr que si je pense que
Emmanuel Macron qui dit un jour le sport
c'est pas politique puis le lendemain
fait ça qui fait de la politique enfin
rien de va là-dedans rien n'est cohérent
qui le disent clairement on a besoin du
pétrole du Qatar au moins ce sera vous
ne pensez pas qu'il en restera quand
même quelque chose ou toute cette
polémique autour de cette Coupe du Monde
au Qatar ah bah sans doute qu'il en
restera quelque chose mais quoi quoi
de positif bah écoutez si la France
gagne sans doute
à part ça je vois pas très bien enfin
des stades de foot climatisés des droits
des personnes bafouées des choix à venir
dans les choix à venir dans les choix à
venir mais j'espère que ça servira mais
quand on voit que les Jeux olympiques
d'hiver pourrait être organisés en
Arabie Saoudite
enfin voilà je crois que là on devient
fou on devient collectivement fou
l'autre sujet d'un autre sujet
d'actualité c'est cette interview c'est
propos de Gabriel attaque hier matin
dans le Parisien il dit que la priorité
du gouvernement ce sont les Français qui
bossent la France laborieuse qui se lève
tous les matins en ayant le sentiment de
travailler pour d'autres c'est ce qu'il
dit quel est votre réaction vous qui
prenez un droit qui apparaissent ce
qu'il déplore d'ailleurs dans cette même
interview et bien je pense que oui les
personnes qui travaillent se lèvent et
n'arrivent pas à finir les fins de mois
et que c'est une souffrance et une
difficulté qui ne fait que s'amplifier
et que ces personnes-là ont précisément
besoin de retrouver des marges de
manœuvre des espaces de respiration donc
il a raison d'en faire sa priorité mais
non pas comme il le font s'il y a pas en
augmentant le temps de travail et en
augmentant pas les salaires c'est à dire
que c'est cette classe laborieuse elle a
besoin qu'on augmente les salaires qu'on
lui donne du temps pour vivre et au
contraire qu'on partage le travail avec
les personnes qui sont au chômage plutôt
que de leur mettre le couteau sous la
gorge en diminuant leurs allocations de
chômage et des augmentations des crédits
d'impôts pour la garde d'enfant qui a eu
des baisses d'impôts depuis 6 milliards
qui a eu des augmentations des tickets
restaurants ben oui une augmentation des
types qui resteront c'est très bien sauf
que il n'y a pas eu d'augmentation de
salaire il n'y a pas eu la moindre
possibilité de discuter d'augmentation
de salaire or ce dont on a besoin là ce
dont ont besoin ces personnes c'est
d'une augmentation de salaire vraiment
la situation sociale devient extrêmement
critique je crois pas que Monsieur Attal
mesure l'ampleur de la crise sociale qui
qui est en train de d'exploser
complètement dans notre pays et là les
premières factures arrivent et ça ne va
faire que s'amplifier dans les mois qui
viennent et je pense que on est face à
de très très grandes difficultés
du grand rendez-vous hier il a parlé de
vous et de votre vision de la gauche on
va l'écouter je vous fais réagir juste
après
la gauche le Cendrine Rousseau elle
représente d'abord une grande confusion
moi je me reconnais pas dans cette
mélasse où on jette à la fois de la
soupe sur des tableaux on soutient les
activistes qui bloquent les routes on
manifeste contre les machines et je n'ai
jamais entendu c'est ça qui m'intéresse
le plus parce que j'étais encore il y a
quelques jours dans l'hémicycle avec son
annonceau je n'ai jamais entendu une
proposition précise à part les actions
chocs on débattre mais jamais une
proposition précise sur l'investissement
dans l'énergie sur l'investissement les
transports jamais
il fallait qu'il soit un peu plus dans
l'hémicycle parce qu'il aurait vu qu'on
soutenait par exemple les 9 milliards
sur la rénovation des logements les 3,5
milliards sur la réflexion du réseau
ferroviaire pour que les trains
fonctionnent et fonctionne mieux parce
qu'on a un problème de réseau il aurait
entendu aussi né un milliard 5 que nous
proposions de mettre sur le train de
nuit il aurait entendu tout cela et en
fait
Clément Boon moi ce que j'entends de lui
c'est en fait la question écologique
n'est jamais à l'ordre du jour n'est
jamais d'actualité n'est jamais au
centre du questionnement et en fait là
ça commence à devenir vraiment très
critique et moi je deviens vraiment très
inquiète de la situation parce que le
mur écologique qui est devant nous que
ce soit sur le climat ou la biodiversité
le mur est d'une et d'une hauteur que
l'on ne mesure pas complètement
aujourd'hui donc là il est temps de
mobiliser notre énergie et notamment
l'énergie de l'État sur la
transformation écologique et c'est
toujours remis à deux mains toujours
remis à après-demain et là maintenant ça
devient vraiment
très très dangereux dangereux Emmanuel
Macron a parlé de notre ambition
écologique c'était hier soir sur sa
chaîne Youtube une nouvelle vidéo
là-dessus et il dit qu'il veut
développer un réseau de RER de train
urbain dans 10 métropoles françaises
justement pour tenir cette ambition
écologique vous êtes contente mais c'est
très bien de faire de nouveaux RER mais
pour ceux qui fréquentent par exemple
les transports parisiens on voit bien
que on est à la rupture aussi dans les
dans les métros il y a l'offre de métro
à diminuer mais métro sont surchargés
parfois il faut attendre trois voire
quatre rames pour pouvoir monter dedans
enfin là
c'est bien de faire des RER mais il y a
pas un euro qui est mis sur les
transports en public de les transports
publics actuels il y a pas un euro qui
est mis sur les transports publics dans
la ruralité donc en fait c'est encore un
problème de financement de cette annonce
il y a pas il y a pas d'argent mis par
l'État sur ces transports en commun et
moi j'ai l'impression que Emmanuel
Macron il se réveille le matin il réunit
son équipe de com il se dit bon bah
qu'est-ce qu'on va annoncer allez dire
RER allez on fait dire RER mais derrière
il y a tout un réseau de transport en
commun qui est en train de s'effondrer
notamment sur la région parisienne mais
pas que et puis sur parce que tout le
réseau ferroviaire dont je vous parlais
et tout doit aussi être il doit y avoir
des investissements sur ce réseau
ferroviaire pour faire en sorte qu'il
fonctionne bien mieux et puis il y a la
ruralité ou pour l'instant rien n'est
fait et donc l'essence augmente et on
laisse les personnes toutes seules
dépendantes face à leur voiture et
complètement dépendante de l'essence et
rien n'est fait donc voilà bon moi les
réunions de com de 10h le matin où on
fait une annonce à midi ça m'intéresse
pas tellement en réalité puisque vous on
va parler d'un autre texte qui concerne
l'écologie c'est le texte sur les
énergies renouvelables le développement
des énergies renouvelables il arrivera
en séance lundi prochain est-ce que vous
allez voter ce texte
alors c'est un texte qui est très
pervers et là il faut il faut quelques
minutes pour expliquer la perversité de
ce texte parce que il faut comprendre
qu'elle va être notre position là-dessus
c'est que en fait on a un texte sur les
énergies renouvelables donc il y a
énergie renouvelable dans le titre donc
on se dit les écolos vont être contents
évidemment puisqu'il y a une énergie
renouvelable dans le titre sauf que
quand on regarde le texte parce que ce
qui est important dans le texte de loi
c'est le texte et bien on s'aperçoit que
les énergies renouvelables sont en fait
le motif pour détricoter le droit de
l'environnement si on utilise
l'implantation des énergies
renouvelables pour détricoter le droit
de l'environnement et bien on fait des
exceptions au droit de l'environnement
on diminue le droit de l'environnement
diminue la protection des milieux pour
être indispensable de modifier le droit
de l'environnement justement évoluer
tout ça alors pas du tout parce
qu'aujourd'hui l'essentiel des projets
d'éoliennes par exemple sont bloqués par
les préfets c'est les préfets qui
bloquent les les projets d'éoliennes
alors que toutes les autorisations ont
été données et que ça respecte tout à
fait le droit le gouvernement vous
entend là-dessus les écologistes sont
discutés avec AG de manière une hachée
notamment sur les questions de la
biodiversité les écologistes discutent
mais pour l'instant en fait on a
l'impression une espèce de stratégie du
gouvernement qui consisterait à dire
voyez vous refusez les énergies fossiles
regardez vous refusez les textes sur les
énergies renouvelables alors qu'en fait
dedans on met plein de vipères à plein
de de choses trappes pour que ça soit
impossible pour nous de le voter et puis
on ne le voit d'ailleurs je ne sais pas
encore si on va le voter ou pas parce
qu'il y a pas de position de vote encore
qui a été définie par le par le groupe
écologiste mais vous personnellement
on ne peut pas utiliser les énergies
renouvelables pour détricoter le droit
de l'environnement il faut bien
comprendre qu'aujourd'hui est possible
aujourd'hui la perte de biodiversité et
majeure elle est on parle d'un
effondrement de la biodiversité on parle
d'un anéantissement de la biodiversité
hier 70% des insectes qui ont disparu
donc en fait on ne peut pas faire comme
si
pour planter une éolienne on pouvait
encore diminuer le droit de
l'environnement c'est pas possible et
bien on est dans un ensemble de
contraintes qui est certes difficile à
gérer mais avec cet ensemble de
contraintes on y arrive très bien la
preuve aujourd'hui ceux qui bloquent
l'implantation d'éolienne ce sont les
préfets c'est pas le droit de
l'environnement donc la véritablement on
utilise un texte encore une fois pour
viser autre chose et on a l'impression
que le gouvernement dit regarder vous ne
voulez pas des énergies fossiles
regardez vous ne voulez pas des ENR donc
il y a plus que le nucléaire enfin
vraiment ayant un débat
c'est pas un nom catégorique mais c'est
un nom c'est mais c'est une position
classique
vous écoute sur cette question de la
biodiversité c'est une position lucide
qui est qui est de dire à Agnès panière
une gouvernement on voit votre stratégie
nous ne sommes pas dupe si elle vous
écoute sur l'action de la biodiversité
pour y aller voter c'est pas un enfer
exactement
sur un autre texte le texte sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'IVG
puisqu'il a été voté la proposition de
la des insoumis a été votée il y a
quelques jours à l'Assemblée est-ce que
vous voterez celle de la majorité
présidentielle qui sera présentée cette
semaine qui sera discuté cette semaine
alors moi j'ai compris que horaire
berger retirait son texte puisque
celui-ci avait accepté donc il a
normalement il devait être étudié
aujourd'hui il a été retiré donc là
c'est très bien c'est ça c'est un bon
point pour le gouvernement c'est-à-dire
qu'ils actent le fait que un texte a été
voté à l'assemblée maintenant le texte
qui a été voté à l'Assemblée doit être
votée conforme au Sénat c'est ce que
j'allais vous demander quel avenir du
coup pour ce texte alors que le Sénat
pour le moment refuse et a refusé de
voter un texte similaire est-ce que
c'est un peu un coup d'épée dans l'eau
il a refusé de mémoire à 17 voix je
crois donc c'est très peu le texte de
Mélanie Vogel votre collègue écologiste
je dis au Sénat attention ne passez pas
à côté de l'histoire ne passez pas à
côté de l'histoire là on a une occasion
assez incroyable de faire en sorte que
la France montre le chemin à bien
d'autres série donne de la force à bien
d'autres femmes dans d'autres
démocraties pour que passe dans les
constitutions le droit à disposer de son
corps donc à 17 voix vraiment
réfléchissez et faites-le et on se
retrouvera en congrès et on votera ce
texte qui sera un texte historique on va
parler politique on va parler de votre
partie puisque le premier tour du
Congrès d'Europe Écologie les vers cette
nuit ce weekend votre candidate la
candidate que vous soutenez est arrivé
en troisième position à moins de 14% des
voix est-ce que c'est un revers pour
vous bah évidemment j'espérais un score
qui soit qui pouvait être un peu
supérieur mais voilà maintenant c'est le
Congrès enfin un congrès c'est un c'est
quelque chose qui se fait c'est un vote
intra-muros et et surtout l'échec pour
moi incroyable de ce congrès c'est qu'on
est passé de 100.000 votants à la
primaire à 5300 sur un congrès on est
passé de 100 000 votants à la place
c'est pas le score de votre candidate
comment voulez-vous que l'écologie
devienne un parti qui
marque qui s'impose qui deviennent la
force motrice d'une du camp progressiste
alors qu'on est 5300 votants et encore
avec des procurations donc ce sont des
placés à mon avis 3000 personnes maximum
3000 personnes alors que c'est l'enjeu
majeur du 21e siècle
marine tondeelier émotion de règlement
intérieur l'aviez-vous qualifié qui est
arrivé en tête ce week-end est-ce que
vous êtes déçu que votre partie n'a pas
vers un peu plus de radicalité
ah mais je salue je salue le score de
Marine tournelier et je me dis je vous
la féliciter parce qu'on vous a peint
trompé
et très bien et voilà maintenant moi ce
que je voudrais c'est vraiment qu'on
sorte de cette espèce d'entre soi
délétère à vraiment une ouverture large
et à faire en sorte qu'on se laisse
déborder par la société civile et
j'espère que Marine tondelee aura cette
intelligence de se faire déborder par la
société civile de faire entrer très
massivement des personnes dans dans le
dans notre partie et de ne pas fermer au
motif qu'on contrôle mieux quand c'est
fermé vous vous craignez ça oui je
crains un peu ça pourquoi mais parce que
je pense que si on est passé de 100 000
personnes à la primaire à 5000 personnes
votant un congrès c'est parce qu'on a
fermé les portes mais ça veut dire que
on aurait vraiment pu agréger beaucoup
de personnes et on a eu peur quand je
dis on a eu peur c'est l'institution
parti politique a eu peur de cette
arrivée massive de personnes ça n'est
pas comme ça qu'on va gagner voilà et
donc j'espère qu'on va ouvrir ça mais
maintenant parce que avant nous n'étions
nulle part parce que je rappelle quand
même que moi je suis arrivée au début de
la primaire j'avais deux militants
écolos donc là voilà on fait 14 %, on
aurait pu espérer mieux très bien c'est
déjà ça on est partout on va être
partout dans les instances y compris
dans les régions donc petit à petit on
va construire quelque chose et vraiment
on touche pas on poussera non je suis
pas déçue je on partait de zéro donc
voilà mais oui évidemment j'aurais
espéré mieux mais on est parti de zéro
j'ai fait 49% à la primaire
justement j'ai fait 49% à la primaire
100 militant écolo
c'est ça qu'il faut bien comprendre et
donc je pense être vraiment en phase
avec une partie de la société cette
partie de la société a du mal à rentrer
dans les partis politiques parce qu'elle
a du mal à s'y retrouver et
particulièrement dans le mien mais c'est
ça qui ne va nous falloir c'est juste
pour qu'on soit là est-ce que vous
soutenez marine Tondelier pour le second
tour
les discussions sont encore en cours et
par ailleurs c'est pas moi c'est Mélissa
Camara
féliciter parce que elle a fait une
campagne absolument incroyable cette
femme est un des avenir de l'écologie
politique et je vous invite vraiment à
regarder son parcours parce que elle
incarne des choses tout à fait mais là
il y a des discussions et Marine
Tondelier va-t-elle nous tendre la main
aux pattes elle est la question est-ce
que vous attendez d'elle si elle nous
tend la main alors évidemment
qu'elle ouvre qu'elle montre son
ouverture vous vous pointez juste le
faible nombre de votants est-ce que ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui pour vous
Europe Écologie est finie et pour
compléter cette question on a quand même
un peu de sentiment quand vous écoute
que vous jouez en dehors du parti
en vous adressant directement à votre
électorat un peu comme la fée Emmanuel
Macron en d'autres temps comme le fait
Laurent Wauquiez en se présentant pas à
la présence du parti
et c'était une question c'était la
question est-ce que vous jouez en dehors
du parking mais en tous les cas parce
que c'est ça votre stratégie non
ça fait partie des règles du jeu que de
participer au Congrès donc on l'a fait
voilà moi je respecte les règles du jeu
on est dans un dans un monde comme ça où
il faut respecter ses règles je le fais
voilà on se présente au Congrès on fait
son score et puis mais après l'essentiel
ne se joue pas non sur un sur un corpus
de 5000 personnes mais justement
aujourd'hui est-ce que Europe Écologie
tel qu'il existe aujourd'hui les morts
alors le parti n'est pas fini mais je
pense que dans la crise démocratique que
nous vivons il y a cette question de la
place des parties ça ça me semble
évident parce que vous citiez Emmanuel
Macron il a gagné la présidentielle sans
parti et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon n'a pas un parti au
sens avec des statues un règlement
intérieur un congrès etc c'est une
formation c'est une force politique mais
c'est pas un parti avec une structure
très établie moi je pense que les
parties permettent la démocratie interne
donc c'est absolument ind responsable
mais par contre la démocratie interne ne
peut pas servir à fermer à ce que ça
soit une boîte complètement fermée de
l'extérieur à l'extérieur donc il nous
faut trouver des modalités pour faire en
sorte que il y ait une forme de fluidité
le militantisme d'aujourd'hui n'est plus
le militantisme d'hier le militantisme
d'hier ressemblait à une sorte de
sacerdoce où on y consacré ces week-ends
d'aujourd'hui ne veulent pas ça les
militants d'aujourd'hui et les
militantes veulent pouvoir militer un
jour repartir revenir faire des actions
discuter politique de manière enflammée
puis repartir et revenir trois semaines
plus tard c'est ça le militantisme
d'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on adapte notre
structure à ça quand Yannick Jadot hier
dans le Journal du Dimanche s'oppose à
votre ligne à votre radicalité dit il
n'y a pas de perspective majoritaire
pour un populisme écolos qu'est-ce que
vous répondez à ça
je sais pas ce que je dois répondre mais
déjà je suis pas qu'est-ce qu'on a pu le
populisme
politique vous êtes en famille là il y a
des choses on a quand même un sujet dans
l'écologie qui est que nous ne sommes
plus en phase avec notre base c'est
quand même un sujet dire que la base
électorale on a vu pour la
présidentielle la base électorale de
l'écologie n'a pas été présente donc
déjà moi j'ai envie de dire consolidon
notre base parlons l'heure faisons en
sorte qu'il se retrouve toutes les
personnes écho anxieuses toutes les
personnes qui attendent une une écologie
fière une écologie impertinente une
écologie aussi qui qui nomme des
adversaires parce que il y a quelque
chose qui me fascine un peu moi dans la
dans des lignes politiques c'est que
c'est comme si l'écologie
n'acceptait pas d'avoir des adversaires
mais enfin
l'écologie a des adversaires politiques
enfin moi je veux dire il prenez le
rassemblement comme il le fait pour vous
c'est pas une femme amener le
rassemblement mais sans masquer n'est
pas l'écologie n'est pas quelque chose
de consensuel à la base en fait il nous
faut changer de système économique
social il nous faut protéger les plus
pauvres il nous faut développer les
biens communs il nous faut taxer les
plus riches taxer les entreprises
limitées l'évasion fiscale à tout ça
évidemment il nous faut transformer
l'agriculture intensive en une
agriculture respectueuse il nous faut
limiter la chasse tout cela évidemment
n'est pas consensuel et il y a des
personnes qui sont contre cela et il
faut l'assumer et il faut l'assumer
parce que notre débat et notre notre nos
positionnement ne gagneront que si on
assume aussi une forme d'adversité il y
a une réaction une élection pardon qui
réussit plutôt pas mal aux écologistes
c'est l'élection européenne est-ce que
vous souhaitez une liste écologiste
simple ou une liste avec la nuque enfin
je j'ai l'impression surtout qu'il est
bien trop tôt pour en parler nous sommes
deux ans à l'avance et que par ailleurs
il est bien trop tôt pour fermer des
portes ça fait partie de ce dont je vous
parlais tout à l'heure de la fermeture
verrouille bien moi je pense que c'est
pas le moment de verrouiller je pense
que c'est le moment de dire que tout est
ouvert et qu'on serait fier et heureux
de pouvoir porter et je dis bien porter
une nouvelle perspective pour l'Europe
et que l'écologie peut porter quand vous
est-ce que vous avez envie de montrer
cette liste aux Européennes bah je suis
député de Paris je peux pas non mais je
vais pas être candidate à toutes les
élections vous pourriez ce n'est pas mon
projet
c'est une question c'est dans deux ans
comme vous dites est-ce que ça vous
tente
à chaque élection non mais ça fait pas
ça sera pas moi mais par contre que
l'écologie porte une dynamique de
renouveau de cette Europe et une Europe
écologique et sociale et ça vraiment je
dis aux partenaires à gauche parce que
vraiment moi je pense que la Nupe ça a
été un espoir et ça a suscité un espoir
j'ai des électeurs et électrices qui
n'avaient pas à choisir entre des
bulletins et qui vraiment avait envie
pas prendre deux ou trois et de les
mettre dans la même enveloppe là il n'en
avait qu'un seul à prendre et à mettre
dans la même enveloppe donc il faut
qu'on continue cette dynamique si ça
n'est pas possible ça n'est pas possible
mais ça n'est pas aujourd'hui qu'on doit
le décider parce que ça vous semble
possible il y a des divisions PS le PS
se déchire sur cette stratégie Fabien
Roussel aussi au sein du parti
communisme même chez vous chez les
écologistes ça divise est-ce que la nuit
pas encore un avenir pour vous moi je
pense que les fiertés des fiertés
isolées ne permettent pas de créer des
dynamiques des dynamiques politiques
voilà pour vous ce sont des fiertés
isolées oui je pense que et
particulièrement parce que le Parti
communiste le Parti communiste a un
congrès le Parti socialiste à un congrès
nous nous sortons d'un congrès enfin
nous sommes en plein milieu d'un congrès
et en fait c'est le moment de congrès
sont des moments de fierté de fierté
identitaire j'ai envie de dire et donc
il faut sortir de ces moments de fierté
identitaire pour construire une
dynamique le sourire vous voulez
épargner les gens de vous présenter
toutes les élections vous avez le
sentiment de parfois vous en faites trop
alors non pas du tout mais par contre je
pense que
notre femme le travail politique que je
fais n'est pas un travail qui consiste à
moi me placer c'est un travail politique
qui consiste à ouvrir un champ politique
et ouvrir un champ politique qui pose la
question sociale la question de
sociétale en même temps que la question
écologiste me dire il n'y a pas de
transformation écologique d'ampleur s'il
n'y a pas en même temps une réforme
profonde de notre société et ça en fait
et donc des rapports de domination et
des rapports d'inégalité sociale au sein
de cette société la transformation
écologique ne sera pas une énième
innovation ça ne sera pas ça ça pourra
l'innovation technologique pourra nous
aider ici ou là mais ça n'est pas ça
fondamentalement qui nous fera changer
de société aujourd'hui on parle de
société de consommation c'est-à-dire
qu'on fait société par la consommation
cela n'est pas une manière de faire
société et donc c'est ce champ là que
j'ouvre et donc et pour ça il me faut un
travail politique dans le long terme et
par ailleurs je je suis député de Paris
et j'entends bien représenter et à
l'Assemblée et sur mon territoire cette
dynamique hier j'étais juste je termine
là-dessus mais j'étais avec une
association de du 13e arrondissement qui
accueille des personnes des enfants en
situation de handicap après l'école
cette association va devoir fermer tout
le mois de décembre parce qu'elle n'a
plus de moyens elle n'a pas assez
d'argent pour ouvrir ça veut dire qu'on
laisse les parents avec des des enfants
en situation de handicap seul à se
débrouiller seul vous vous rendez compte
de la violence de cette société moi je
ne veux pas de ça un mot puisqu'on
parlait de la nuque sur Adrien catenens
puisque hier Clémentine Autain député de
la France insoumise à dire a dit que la
démission n'était pas l'axe choisie par
la France insoumise est-ce que vous
regrettez ça
je pense que Adrien katnas ne peut pas
représenter le peuple français il ne
peut pas représenter les hommes et les
femmes en l'état actuel voilà donc vous
continuez ce matin à demander sa
démission moi je demande à ce qu'ils ne
viennent pas à l'Assemblée je pense que
c'est les filles de prendre ma décision
pour savoir papa aux décisions la ville
du groupe jusqu'à la décision judiciaire
est-ce que c'est suffisant là il y a une
instruction judiciaire et il faut que
cette instruction aille rapidement
maintenant moi je voudrais dire parce
qu'il n'y a je crois qu'il n'y a presque
jamais eu de parole comme ça de dire je
crois Céline cadenas
et je pense que sa parole doit être
respectée sa parole doit être respectée
et donc sur cette base là alors
Adrien katnas doit se mettre en retrait
et quelque part on est dans une minute
en retrait est-ce qu'il faut qu'il
démissionne oui mais moi je pense qu'il
faut qu'il réfléchisse à la démission on
est dans un on est dans un moment
politique très particulier où la
politique qui était faite pour les
hommes et par les hommes ou ce genre de
violence sur les femmes n'étaient pas un
sujet ça n'était pas un sujet ça n'était
pas un sujet politique aujourd'hui ça
devient un sujet politique alors oui
c'est difficile alors oui ce sont des
évolutions qui sont compliquées et oui
on le voit à l'intérieur de chaque parti
politique sacré des tensions et pas des
petites tensions mais maintenant on est
dans ce moment là est-ce qu'on
accompagne ce changement ou est-ce qu'au
contraire on met le frein pour éviter de
et pour se replier sur un monde qui
quand même un monde de domination
masculine moi je dis ouvrons ouvrons et
prenons la mesure de ce qui est en train
de se passer dans la société et très
rapidement Fabrice une question pour les
journaux du groupe Evra oui Dominique
Voynet a été élu ce week-end à Dole sa
ville
secrétaire donc des enfin la tête des
vers Franche-Comté que vous inspire le
retour en politique de cette figure de
l'écologie française c'est 30 dernières
années moi j'ai pas de problème à ce
qu'elle revienne en politique j'ai un
problème à ce qu'elles prennent des
responsabilités en politique puisque
voilà il y a eu un moment qui était un
moment très important au sein de
l'écologie et du parti écologiste ça a
été l'affaire Baupin c'était la première
affaire de violence sexuelle quand même
au sein d'un parti politique et un an
avant Mitou
ça a été très dur pour nous de parler ça
a été extrêmement compliqué je rappelle
qu'à l'époque personne ne parlait de
cela
qu'on était les premières à le faire on
a été quatre puis on a été sept puis on
est à la fin je crois que on était 14 à
avoir parlé pour les comportements de
niveau pain et puis il y a eu un procès
que Denis Baupin nous a intenté en
diffamation c'est lui qui nous a fait ce
procès pour nous faire taire c'est des
fameux procès Bayons nous avons gagné ce
procès et nous avons gagné même des
dommages pour procédure abusives bien
Dominique voine qui était une ancienne
secrétaire nationale de notre parti
politique a été témoin en faveur de
Baupin contre nous contre nous et c'est
un acte politique d'avoir fait ça et ça
n'est pas vrai qu'elle a été convoquée
par la justice et qu'elle n'avait pas le
choix François de Rugy était dans la
même situation et il a refusé de venir
donc en fait je veux dire c'était un
acte politique qu'est-ce qu'on veut
est-ce qu'on est un parti féministe ou
est-ce que nous ne le sommes pas je
crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut répondre à
cette question merci beaucoup Sandrine
Rousseau merci d'avoir été notre invité
ce matin merci Fabrice